Тільки Пфайзер. Якщо запропонують Джонсон і Джонсон, то краще вже коронавірус.
У соцмережах, здається кожен знає, яка вакцина найкраща, а яка - найгірша.
Люди люблять порівнювати. Тож не дивно, що ми робимо це і з вакцинами проти "ковіду".
Проблема в тому, що порівнювати вакцини не так просто.
А сама лише спроба може зашкодити в часи пандемії.
Ми схильні зосереджуватися на оцих цифрах - показниках ефективності.
Адже вони вимірюють, наскільки ймовірно, що ви інфікуєтесь COVID-19 після вакцинації.
Проблема в тому, що ці показники не були отримані за однакових умов.
Вони дуже залежали від часу і місця проведення випробувань.
Я думаю, що просте порівняння ефективності вакцин поза контекстом
може призвести до дуже неправильних висновків.
Існують ключові відмінності в популяціях досліджень.
Наприклад, вік, стать, генетичні та екологічні фактори, вже наявні захворювання.
Як же відбуваються випробування на ефективність?
Учасників ділять на дві групи. Одна група отримує вакцину, інша - плацебо.
Потім вони продовжують жити своїм звичайним життям.
Через певний проміжок часу дослідники підраховують, скільки з них інфікувалися COVID-19.
Якщо всі учасники, які захворіли, походять з групи плацебо,
і жоден - із групи вакцин, тоді вакцина вважається на 100% ефективною.
А якщо абсолютно однакова кількість людей з обох груп захворіла,
ефективність вакцини вважається нульовою.
Оскільки ризик зараження завдяки вакцині не зменшився.
Але ймовірність того, що піддослідні захворіють під час випробувань,
залежить від загального рівня зараження в їхньому середовищі.
Існують також відмінності залежно від наявності або відсутності різних
варіантів вірусу, які більш або менш ефективно нейтралізуються антитілами,
що виробляються під впливом спайкового білка оригінального вірусу з Уханю.
Це той, який включили до нинішніх вакцин.
Тож, хоча ми думаємо, що знаємо, яка вакцина найкраща,
насправді, на нашу думку вплинули ситуативні фактори.
Випробування Moderna та Pfizer проводилися здебільшого в США
і ще до прибуття варіантів вірусу з Великобританії чи Південної Африки.
Натомість Тести AstraZeneca або Johnson & Johnson проводились або пізніше,
або в країнах, де з’явилися більш інфекційні варіанти вірусу, які стали домінуючими.
Тож показники ефективності ніколи не будуть абсолютно однаковими в реальних умовах.
А з часом вони можуть змінюватися.
Наприклад, нещодавно ми отримали звіт з Катару, де близько 50 відсотків інфекцій
спричинені південноафриканським та британським варіантами.
Ці дослідження показують нам, що ефективність вакцини BioNTech/Pfizer падає
до вісімдесяти дев'яти та сімдесяти п'яти відсотків у випадку з інфекціями,
спричиненими британським та південноафриканським варіантами.
Але, можливо, досі було занадто багато уваги до ефективності.
Зазвичай ефективність є орієнтиром для найкращого можливого результату -
абсолютної відсутності симптомів.
Натомість ми можемо поглянути на те, як вакцини дозволяють запобігати госпіталізації
та смертям від COVID-19. Адже всі ці вакцини роблять це однаково добре.
Є ще один аспект, який впливає на те, як ми оцінюємо вакцини.
Побічні ефекти.
Повідомлення про дуже рідкісні випадки тромбів викликали занепокоєння у людей.
ЄС теж вирішив не продовжувати свої контракти з AstraZeneca та J&J.
Все це, очевидно, створило враження, що деякі вакцини гірші за інші.
Але знову ж таки, все не так просто.
Оскільки індивідуальний ризик зараження впливає на оцінку того,
наскільки корисною є кожна вакцина.
Погляньмо на приклад вакцини від AstraZeneca та припустимо помірний рівень зараження -
55 випадків на 100 000.
Зі 100 000 людей у віці до 29 років - приблизно у двох осіб після вакцини AstraZeneca
буде розвиватися рідкісне згущення крові.
Водночас ніхто не потребував би інтенсивної терапії з інфекцією Covid-19.
Але особи старше 60 років набагато частіше потрапляють в реанімацію з COVID-19
і рідше у них розвивається рідкісне згущення крові.
Ось чому деякі уряди рекомендують вакцину AstraZeneca лише людям у віці 60+.
Але ця оцінка змінюється, щойно рівень зараження стає вищим.
Давайте подивимось на розрахунки у ситуації з вищим рівнем зараження -
401 випадок на 100 000.
Тут усі з більшою ймовірністю потрапляють до реанімації з COVID-19,
ніж отримують тромб після вакцинації.
У цьому випадку зиск від отримання вакцини AstraZeneca перевищує ризик
рідкісних тромбів для всіх вікових груп.
Звичайно, для профілактичного втручання, спрямованого на здорових людей,
тобто для вакцинації, дуже важливо, щоб співвідношення користі та ризику
було прийнятним для різних груп населення або навіть для окремих людей.
Тож чи гірші одні вакцини за інші?
Якщо ми просто подивимось на побічні ефекти, деякі з них працюють дещо краще -
принаймні з того, що ми знаємо на сьогодні.
Але це лише один аспект, і він не повинен бути єдиним, на який ми маємо зважати.
Я думаю, ключовий момент ось у чому: найкращою вакциною є та,
яка дозволяє запобігти захворюванню та смерті.
І, звичайно, зменшити прямі та непрямі наслідки, негативні наслідки пандемії.
Будь-яка з вакцин, що отримали екстрене схвалення ВООЗ,
захищає від важких випадків COVID-19.
Вони запобігають смертності та допомагають припинити цю пандемію.
Отже, поки вакцин не вистачає, є вагомий аргумент прищепитись тією, яка доступна.
Тому що, якщо ми будемо наполягати на отриманні конкретної вакцини,
то лише продовжимо цю пандемію. А це може коштувати людських життів.